all right the last couple general
managers spots were filled on
tuesday i don't think it's official yet
but it's been reported trent balcke the
former 49ers general manager will be the
new general manager of the jaguars he
was the interim gm i had heard over the
weekend that balky was the guy who was
going to land with urban meyer in
jacksonville and stay actually balky's
been there he took over the job on an
interim basis i think it's great that
the guy who
became the arch enemy of jim harbaugh in
san francisco and harbaugh now the
michigan coach is going to be the gm for
the former ohio state coach i love that
wrinkle to this chris all right well i
do too because you know i'm not a big
jim harbaugh fan so i love that really
yeah i hadn't heard that o-h-i-o okay
there we go but either way
um
i understand i think the marriage there
certainly i mean you know two guys
similar age group
uh bucky's been around the nfl has great
experience as far as hey i know this is
your first time around the nfl i'm not
some huge overpowering figure but i've
been there done that and we can work
together and build something here and i
don't i would think
i would think
urban meyer has control of the roster
right this would be one of those type of
things right yes yeah okay he's in
charge yeah let me tell you i've
probably told you this before but just
humor me i'm old you know you got to
humor the
the aging and let them tell their same
story 50 times someone told me that one
of the league events whether it was a
meeting or the combine or whatever
riding an elevator stops on one floor
opens the doors trent bauke gets on
doors close go to the next floor doors
open jim harbaugh gets on they're
working together
arm in arm at the time with the 49ers i
feel like i've heard that they don't
even speak to each other right right
amazing amazing how bad that
relationship was yeah that lasted as
long as it did given how how bad it was
all right uh so bowkey the gm with urban
meyer i assume that when they get on the
elevator they will talk to us
at least at least for the first year
right uh in washington two guys who
definitely will talk if they end up on
the same elevator
marty herney and ron rivera reuniting
now that hernia had been fired by the
panthers the difference here though in
washington will be rivera is in charge
now right
that's been the most overlooked aspect
of the washington football team dynamic
over the course of the last year with
all the twists and turns and dysfunction
etc rivera is in charge
and i'd rather have her very in charge
and bruce allen frankly uh and uh rivera
is making good moves and i think marty
hernia's going to make some good
decisions and that team is going to
continue to get better and better how
they got to the playoffs that's right uh
in in a year that that was as messed up
as any team has been through and i think
that the future's bright for the
washington football team agreed stable
human beings that's the thing that i
come back to with both of these guys ron
rivera i mean this is an organization
that's you know just right on the
outside of the dysfunction wheel from
the houston texans and the philadelphia
eagles and uh ron rivera has calmed a
lot of that down and a guy like marty
herney again been there for a long time
built a sustained winner there in
carolina where they were relevant for a
lot of years and i don't think the power
structure matters i think that's why
it's going to work great together they
see the game the same way and
i i'm with you mike washington seems
like they're doing all the right things
and headed down the right path
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports